ich habe freunde gefunden ich habe noch
nie heimlich einfach von meinen eltern
geklaut
nein ich meine geschwister neben mir
meine schwester tabea aber mein bruder
wachsen zusammen im familienurlaub und
das heißt es gibt für euch neue videos
zusammen leute heute spielen wir
zusammen ich habe noch nie unterfangen
direkt an mit der ersten frage
gefahren werde ausgehöhlt und maxis von
sarah die in der kamera und wir legen
jetzt lust leute gesagt japan weckt mich
einfach mal erzählt es ist mittlerweile
wirklich zu krank wie viele von meinen
verwandten und familie freunden von
meinen eltern diese video schaut ihr
freunde oder eltern freunde von meinen
eltern zudem seien sie nicht diese wie
ich höre mir die sachen machen und so
egal ob ja 321 letztlich war ich hab den
so es sein könnte aus gründen nicht
weiter darauf eingehen denn sie ist noch
auf der schule
ich kann ja haus sozusagen tabea kann
aus gründen darauf nicht weiter eingehen
sie ist noch an der schule ganz kurz
vorm ihre ich hatte mein lehrer der ließ
man den hatte ich in mathe und ich war
sehr rebellisch in diesem jahr und ich
habe ihn ganz nett hermann genannt
oh mein gott ich hätte einfach so
richtig cool religion ja was man dann
kopflos religionslehrer wahrscheinlicher
und deutlich der relegation daten würden
beigebracht ihnen die
bundesliga-relegation upload
ich habe noch nie eigentlich eine von
meinen eltern geklaut
nein nein wir machen hier ja leider
macht einfach nicht weiter wir lässt das
macht ihn doch europas seien die
flugzeuge dar am haus vorbei egal wer
das nicht gemacht hat ist zum ich habe
schon 15 mal habe ich mal so der zur
sauce zum kochen und mama einmal
ernsthaft weg und ich hab einfach den
berg getrieben und die andreas das ist
immer noch so im keller einfach so viel
besser als das wasser aufgefüllt
das glaube ich sage überlegen als er
muss auch nicht zu sagen hat glaube ich
jedoch nicht max abräumer alles auf mich
geschrieben habt ihr auch nicht geschaut
ich habe mich wird sowieso immer als
erstes geschoben wo man ist ja auch ich
hab einfach sein
er war wirklich schön zu hören
wer war gestern schuld dass wir noch mal
das tor zurück fahren mussten
[Musik]
wieder und udo may oder we don't do re
mi treffen warum auch so herr
also was ist der grund sei dass man den
verkäufen im bruder durch da bin ich mir
leider nicht ganz
ich würde wünschte eigentlich hätte es
gemacht aber ich kann es nicht mit
sicherheit sagen also wir haben auf
jeden fall schon mal gemeinsam so
temporär hat wird sich das jetzt mal
gehen nicht mittendrin ein jahr auf
einem privatgelände wo und freunden und
straßenschilder hat haben wir einmal wie
abgemacht ja und ich bin nach hause
genommen stimmen vorher konzert nämlich
ein der straßenschilder verleih und da
wir uns erst mal bisschen umgeschaut und
ist optimal sehen somit sterne ja das
neue straßenschild
ja gut das ist doch nicht starten kann
ja auch freundin von sebastian und/oder
mir sein und besser also es geht ja eh 3
2 1
ich würde guckt erstmal was wir anderen
machen nicht verhängt werden
05 die verbindung sei schlecht
jeden tag haben und nicht auf ernst
eigentlich aus wenn er mal ist es nur so
aufzug musik ist ja wirklich so dass er
den ihm schlechter es gibt tagen von mir
und dann rufen wir alle drei minuten an
und sie können filme feinheiten neues
album also die auch jockey aber nie auch
ernst denn er war erwarten so ein rezept
schreiben ich und mein bester mann
damals haben einst von chefkoch.de
gegeben
ein briefe geschickt lehre mit der url
von dem rezept aber ich hab das ständig
gehabt nur irgendwann wurde ich zu
schauen damit die leute mit komplett
umgeschrieben und sonst hat er verbinde
[Musik]
ich glaube also unfall würde man sagen
es mit anderen verkehrsteilnehmern die
besten leute ich habe es ja nur fünf
grad könnte es endlich sehen manche also
ich hab noch nicht also durch zeige ich
hab' ich hab ich mal den unfall
verursacht dass dafür meine ich jetzt
nicht so mit park so ein paar kratzer
oder so
das muss mit anderen autos eigentlich
wären oder in allen personen die
beteiligten im rhein gefahren ich war
einmal nach eingefahren aber ich bitte
dich mich nicht ich bin mal mit lina die
wir hinten nach dem krieg träger und
moderner hat frau erfahren tätigkeiten
um die torturen also ich habe die dann
umgebracht
das war einfach normal
[Musik]
ich kann mich jetzt auch an keinen
konkreten fall erinnern ehrlich gesagt
aber ich gehe jetzt mal nach
wahrscheinlichkeit und da ist wirklich
hier mal ganz was denn wenn ich mein
verhalten des tieres wurde auch schon
von der jetzigen ja nichts
also wir reden drehen wir so von dem
geflügel leute sind ja otto geschrieben
hat
das wird für haye klar weil ich meinen
bruder so von tabea video fertig doch
etwas stabiler gemacht hat zu wird
seinen garten getanzt wird
das muss jetzt ganz vereinzelt in der
stelle nein das kannst du dir hier
[Musik]
ich habe hier ein liebesgedicht china
die jungen männer ein gedicht hut ab
lustig ist lasse ich kann es euch zeigen
ich habe als dieses geld so bei mir in
der franz gruppe ich habe als kleiner
also comics geschrieben als in der 6
typen der ist lukas und der ist weg zur
stelle
manche sachen müssen einfach ans
tageslicht kommen ja manchmal machen
geschwister einfach so weist das kranke
legal sachen dass man glücklich damit an
eine hohe autorität gegen
[Gelächter]
ich habe mir das nicht außen vor war
ausgeschaltet ist meine geschwister drin
waren
ich glaub ich glaube ein absoluter nie
gegönnt hätte halt nicht weil du
derjenige bist der nach halbe stunde im
staat drin ist mit seinem handy man sagt
die ganze ist ja mal fragen helfen drin
so tik tok sounds werden wenn man sie
besten sechs sebastian also andere läuft
so ein bisschen disco fieber können so
wenn der drin ist und ja das wird ja
okay gut so ja aber nicht ausgelassen
dass das nicht so für diese eine sekunde
zählt das aus studio ihr klar ja auch
gedacht
alle für das war so weit von uns allen
sind soweit sie ist wollen in dem
schreiben verlinkte kriegt jetzt durch
vorgeschaltete hier könnte man meinen
das ist dann die